>> Shocking news.
Just kidding, not shocking at all.
A new study finds that
raising the minimum wage,
a sort of reasonable amount relative to
the cost of living, has economic benefits
and generally improves people's lives.
Many right-wingers will tell you
that if you raise the minimum wage,
especially to $15 an hour,
as many Democrats want to do,
it'll be the Apocalypse.
Businesses will close,
widespread unemployment.
Unfortunately, the facts
don't really bear that out.
We have a new study
conducted by UC Berkeley
which proves the opposite.
They looked at Seattle, Washington,
and they looked at
Seattle's $15 minimum wage,
and it worked really, really well.
The study used the rest
of Washington's economy
as a sort of control to predict
what would have happened
in Seattle if they had not increased
the minimum wage to $15.
On January 1st of this year,
the $15 minimum wage took effect,
and now unemployment
is lower than it's been
in Seattle for nearly a decade.
In Seattle, wages are up,
unemployment is down,
and the number of hours worked is up,
meaning that employers
aren't cutting hours
to account for the higher minimum wage.
This was even true in
the restaurant industry,
even at fast food restaurants,
which is a common example from the right.
The conservatives like to say,
when you raise the minimum wage,
it's particularly bad for
fast food restaurants,
and the truth is, people
weren't being laid off
in the way Republicans said would happen.
The higher minimum wage drew people
to those fast food jobs, not away,
and those workers are
also able to themselves,
as a result of earning a higher salary,
have a higher standard of living.
These are meaningful trends.
The data here is really impactful.
Because Seattle didn't just suddenly
raise its minimum wage six months ago,
they've been slowly and steadily
raising it over the last several years
up to $15 per hour at the
beginning of this year,
and things have been
progressively getting better
and better since the
beginning of these increases.
The study found that instead
of the new minimum wage
making it harder for businesses to find
what are called low-skill employees,
it's causing surrounding communities
to raise their wages to compete with
the new opportunities in Seattle.
Companies are struggling when they're not
paying their workers enough instead of
the other way around.
You hear, oh, if minimum wage goes up,
that will make companies struggle.
No, the companies not paying
the higher wages are struggling.
And some of this is pretty intuitive.
If people have more money to spend,
because the minimum wage went up,
that will help businesses,
including fast food.
Since people earning in that range
are more likely to go to fast
food restaurants as well.
And more and more people are working,
they're working more hours,
they're getting paid more,
all of which stimulates the economy.
Seattle is the first major city
to raise its minimum wage in this way,
and this is now going to become
part of a larger study at Berkeley
to look at other cities
raising their minimum wages.
This is very good news.
>> Right, and conservatives
have this talking point
that if you raise the minimum wage,
then you have to make up for it
by lowering hours, or
cutting staff in some way,
as if there's no other factors there.
And I understand that a company may
budget out a certain
amount to labor costs,
but there's other things
in that pie chart.
Like, for example, corporate profits,
and when you're talking
about big companies
like McDonald's or Walmart,
they can easily afford to do that.
>> No doubt about it.
It is not a linear relationship.
If you raise wages X,
you don't have to raise all prices
that exact same percentage.
And by the way, there's
another really common
conservative talking point
from those who try to
debunk the minimum wage,
which is listen, if
$15 is better than $12,
and more money for everybody is good,
why not make the minimum
wage $200 an hour,
and then everything would be great?
See?
You couldn't, so you shouldn't raise
the minimum wage at all.
No one is asking for that.
That is a total red herring.
That is not an equilibrium wage,
given the cost of
living, and productivity,
and what you need to make in order to have
a livable wage.
There's no economic argument
for a $200 an hour minimum wage.
Just because $15 is better than $12,
or maybe $18 would be better than $15,
it doesn't mean that any serious people
are calling for a $200 minimum wage,
so please, do not fall for that
when right wingers say that if
raising the minimum wage is good,
just keep on raising it.
It's not a serious economic argument
that anybody is making.